over the last year few animes have been
slated more for their poor animation
than Dragon Ball super house heck even I
talked about the premiere acts poor
animation does Dragon Ball super have
any good animation to showcase does it
outweigh the bad
the answer is of course it does but
you'll have to decide for yourself I
however think it's high time I drew some
attention to the great animation this
arc had to offer it's a subject not many
have praised in video but alas I shall
boldly go where few have gone before me
I am a huge fan of Dragon Ball super and
I'm going to show you why so sit back
relax and enjoy the top 10 best animated
moments of Dragon Ball super battle of
gods Ark number 10 the fiery eyes of Qi
Qi episode would in my previous video I
aim some of my criticism at how at times
the characters depicted in the series
were quote off model for a drawing to be
on model means the drawing has to match
or resembled beyond any reasonable doubt
the original designs for the character
and you guessed it those original
designs come from the head honcho
himself mr. Akira Toriyama who was still
working on the show today and while
Critias loss of 12 inches still escapes
me this scene showcased chichi to
absolute perfection featuring some
beautiful fire animation on the eyes
also noting how the view slowly swoops
in as her face slowly turns some nice
movement in the hair as well this scene
might not be as flashy as I was on this
list
but I'm a sucker for beautiful
expressive animation capturing that kind
of emotion mixed with a slow-motion turn
is not easy or cheap to animate and was
massively produced by the talented katsu
Yoshi
nakatsu ro thank you very much sir
number 9 the Cheetahs gravity chamber
training episode to take it from the
same episode that featured four cheetahs
family vacation this sequence in the
gravity chamber showcases some light
combat animation mixed with some very
accurate art some might not agree that I
take art into account when looking at
the animation but animation no matter
how great is useless if the characters
do not look like the characters but this
seam delivers in a surprisingly big way
ed I gotta say produces some nicely
drawn hands to boot angles we don't
normally see
dynamic exciting movement and it was all
thrown together with so OnPoint
artwork
Yuki Hayashi Atos amo Ishikawa arigato
to you sir number eight Goku's entrance
episode eight remember the last episode
when I criticized the Cheetahs fight
with beerus in episode 8 calling it
hokey lacking in flow and energy well I
guess we know where the budget for that
would take it from the very same episode
this is an awesome entrance for Goku
give it a full 360 degree panic shot at
various angles and distances some very
nice hair animation and again excellent
artwork the icing on the cake however
bean Goku's descent again everything is
on model and the animation looks
spectacular they could have taken the
easy and cheap way out by using a
section of that looping it while scaling
the same animation of creating the
illusion that he is moving closer and
closer to the camera but instead
thank God they decided to draw new
frames as he moved closer to the camera
giving it a more grounded organic feel
with much more energy and personality
mr. Koji - she's our take a bow number 7
goku vs beerus episode 11 ok this will
be the last time this fight features in
this list take her from episode 11 it
also won't be the last time that mr.
Naoki today's name will be mentioned
either now one of tOA's most prolific
animators he is slowly becoming one of
my favorites - what he might lack in
detail is more than made up for his
action sequences with facial and body
expression taking liberties with the
anatomy of his characters to create a
scene that is truly a unique sight to
behold the scene in question features a
great Kamehameha with a unique angle and
some truly spectacular dust clouds and
explosions I could gosh all day about
this guy but instead I highly recommend
you check out his work for yourself you
won't regret it
number 6 alien vs. Dino with
transformation episode - oh hey Yuki
Hayashi fantasy new again this might not
be one of the moments many of you were
expecting to feature in this list let
alone so high up heck I bet some of you
don't even remember it but this sequence
taken from episode 2 is pretty amazing
featuring nice composition contrasting
colors and a crazy good fire sequence
not to mention we get a nice bit of
action too topped off with a
surprisingly good transformation given
the level of importance this scene holes
in the series
regardless of how important you think it
is it sure is pretty so
sit back and enjoy number five goku vs
beerus episode ted following the
controversy surrounding episode 5 and a
disappointing Vegeta fight in episode 8
this arc spinel clip battle between lord
beerus god of destruction and Super
Saiyan God Goku needed to deliver in a
big way and boy oh boy did Osamu
Ishikawa help do just that
delivering scene after scene with
stunning animation complex aerial fight
sequences with great great camera work I
particularly enjoy the moment Goku was
taken aback by just how fast he was
spiraling out of control flailing wildly
it was a very nice touch all in all it's
one of the strongest episodes from an
animation perspective I think at times
certain characters looked a little off
model in my opinion not a huge amount
but enough to push our next clip ahead
by a nose
speaking of which number four the
Cheetahs vacation episode two here he is
back again with some more stunning
animation mister Naoki Tata proving that
OE has some truly brilliant animators
making a splash with some great water
cloud and aerial animation although
brief this scene demonstrates exciting
visuals in a way we don't often see and
in what was a pretty laid-back episode -
the animation was supervised by Osamu
Ishikawa and I have to say is probably
the most solid episode on this list if
you're talking about animation beautiful
color great composition everything is on
model and the movement is flawless this
one is definitely gonna be hard to beat
number three goku vs beerus episode 13
the second last episode of this arc
delivered a smorgasbord of tasty
animated goodness most notable of which
from 1 Yuya Takahashi taking inspiration
from naio Toshi Tschida who was
responsible for this masterpiece in the
battle of gods movie in 2013 paying
tribute to the incredible animator Yuya
proves that he too is no slouch when it
comes to the Illustrated moving picture
he knows just how to frame a shot and
knows exactly the right notes to hit to
bring the audience on a ride - remember
there is real talent here and I hope to
see more from him in the episodes to
come great episode overall with some
great incredible memorable artwork
number 2
Goku's kamehameha and King Kai's planet
episode 5
before I get slated for having the ugly
stepchild of scenes as we're number two
allow me to explain myself while this
scene is by and large bad
there is one jewel in this ocean of joke
animated by the talented kid Otsuka and
overseen by the okay Tata this one short
scene demonstrated exactly what I look
for in Dragonball sequence action
intensity emotion and explosions it's
probably the clip I look at most from
this arc and for good reason it may be
short but the expression contrast
framing energy and excellent artwork
come together to produce something truly
special this is one of the few moments I
think the actually did better the movie
this is one of my favorite clips of the
entire series and it has earned its
place as my number two honorable mention
opening animation by Cody Watanabe as an
honorable mention I decided to show some
appreciation to Cody what's not it for
some of the animations that is used in
the opening credits of the show well you
might have known was that he's
responsible for some of the best
animated moments of Dragon Ball Z's
resurrection of F movie thank you for
that mr. Cody Watanabe number one goku
vs beerus finale episode 14 coming in at
number one is the last episode of the
ark codes deadly featuring the climax to
the battle of the gods
after working on shows like one piece
episode of Bardock at the battle of gods
movie which is animated incredibly go
watch it really she shows us exactly why
he is one of the best animators in Japan
today packed to bursting with energy
high-octane action even some underwater
combat this episode has it all
adventures up next too many of Dragon
Ball Z suits there isn't anything I can
really complain about when I watch this
it's just simply gorgeous animation for
me Dragon Ball has always represented
fun action expression freedom it's a
world where we could all believe that
people can fly and do incredible things
it's a place I got lost it as a child as
an adult I can say it helps shape the
man that I am today
when times were at their darkest I could
always draw and escape back to the world
that brought me so much joy and
excitement in my youth it's thanks to
Dragon Ball that I'm stunning animation
in college and why I'm following my
dreams it has always been my favorite
show and it still is too
a I hope that at least some of my
excitement and enthusiasm for the series
came through in this video it's a great
arc with some brilliant animation and I
hope I encourage some of you to give
this Acker another chance if you guys
like to see more or less like this one
please subscribe for more I've been
toying up mark and this has been the 10
best animated moments of Dragon Ball
super battle of gods arc thank you so
much for watching